musician landscape of nature great quick
thanks for coming thanks for having me
here
so I'm Tony MA this is based on joint
work with Jason Lee from USC underground
go from Duke University I'm at Facebook
is research as a budding scientist for
this year and I'll be joining Stanford
afterwards so electus start by
discussing a little bit about what I see
as the interfaces between users and
optimizers for the machine learning
cycles so so let's some first discuss
what's the typical you know interfaces
between users optimization researchers
but it's kind of simple right so the
users send a function to the optimizers
this will describe the function and
optimizers you know needs to decide you
know what to do the optimization
research is to decide what to do maybe
we use a very simple algorithm that we
need assent our local search algorithm
for this quick case oh we could if the
problem is very you know complicated
maybe we need to use some combat
rotation or rounding or maybe we need
some other you know algorithms but you
know doesn't matter what you I would
have to be use then at the end of the
day we need to send the solution back to
the user and I think and that's it so
another solution is to satisfy hours no
constraints under so and so forth right
if the original problem is this query
optimization then we need to send back
discrete solutions so and in machine
learning you know in the past several
years people have been you know make
this interface it'll be more flexible
and by you know having more features you
know this is not in the past few years
but you know for a lot of years and
people have you know studied it borrows
different settings for example you can
describe a set of different features
about the functions for example f is a
function is a sum of functions and each
of these I files could be come back
smooth in strongly convex you know so
and so forth and it could be have some
condition number condition so and so
forth so you have a list of you know
small set of features and then the
optimization researcher needs to decide
what I wouldn't use we have a sum of
functions maybe stock customization is a
good algorithm or maybe you can use some
advanced version like saga as TCS vrg so
and so forth and of course that the
not today you still need to fund a
solution and send it back to the user so
what a block what do I have left of you
here is that there may be emotion
earning nowadays in multi machine
learning we can have some slightly
different more flexible interfaces so
that we can you know have more progress
especially in a non-combat SWAT by the
way you know most of this talk is
concerned about you know we concern
about you know a non-convex compensation
so in an unclassified non-convex well
you know the problem is pretty hard so
maybe we need to be more flexible so
after receiving this function from the
users maybe the first question which you
asked is whether this function is easy
for us you know you can have different
type of interpretation for this question
maybe this can be interpreted either
this function is in principle you know
you know fundamentally whether we can
solve it in polynomial time
or we can include interpret this
question as whether we can have a fast
algorithm for it all you can interpret
as you know whether the existing
algorithms can solve it like stock
customs and can solve it and if the
answer is no then we need to go back and
ask okay maybe this function is too hard
for us can you change the batch function
usually you can't do this in a classical
setting because you know the function f
is really our problem but in most
learning we have this flexibility
because no users can say okay maybe let
me try a new model and a new loss
function so just in case you know you're
not very familiar with machine learning
so in machine learning just recall that
in for example in supervised learning a
model is a parametric function of the of
the input the input is X and we have G
theta which is paralysed by theta and
the y hat is our prediction and why is
the Trulie policy and given the true
label and the prediction we can have a
loss function L and we care often about
the expectation of the loss over the you
know the distribution of X so we see
that you know G Sedan L are something
that we can change possibly especially
the model itself so we don't really care
about the model itself you know as long
as it has you know good error then then
probably spot so so that's why we can
change the model and change the loss
function and we have a new function of
crime and we send it back to the
optimization researcher and probably
these functions
and we say okay let's use some simple
algorithm let's talk a stick with inset
and then we send solution for F Prime
back to the user and here the important
thing is that we don't have to do any
wrongdoing because we really just care
about F prime we don't already we can
already forgot about F we don't have to
you know be good on earth we only need
to be good on life crap so this is a
little related what int I talked about
right so in tax talk so here so you know
sequence move sequence of smoothing of
the original function but at the end of
day his teen is to find the solution for
our original function but here we don't
really care that much about it so it'll
be easier so and you know and actually a
lot of you know recent progress
especially empirical progress in deep
learning are really you know following
this paradigm so value you know
rectifier our linear unit so this is
some activation function that replaces
the sigmoid in recent days so this is
really just changing the optimization
problem and make it easier and also over
permutation meaning you change to make
the model bigger and bigger and bachelor
ization and in brasilia networks are
ways to you know change the model so
that optimization becomes easier so that
you can optimize deep models so and so
forth so in this talk I'm not going to
really have enough things to support
these things so you know but what I'm
only going to focus on is this this
question is this function easy to me can
we have any mathematical ways to decide
what functions are easy you know
understanding the landscape of the
functions so so this is the part you
know given this thought you know this is
the kind of paradigm that is possible
from optimization theory machine
learning
so the first step you know is 25 family
of functions that are tractable again
I'm talking about continuous functions
you know and then we might think okay
can we decide whether a function belongs
to this family F and the third step is
whether we can you know these are new
models and object functions that can
prove play B in the fact the set s so
I'm not saying that these three steps
has to be done in order we can you know
and actually I'm I think that we should
you know
to each of these step you know in
parallel in sometimes but this might be
a reasonable paradigm and so just to
briefly summarize the kind of state of
our the best we know for approximate the
best we know for all of this in your
questions so for the federal functions
this is probably the largest or one of
the largest families functions that we
know how to optimize in continuous words
so if the function satisfies the our
local minima or most of the local minima
approximate global then we can hope to
find the approximate global minima so
for example you know basically they're
saying that you know many other
functions in machine learning we can't
check sure that they have this properly
a local minima global this is saying
that okay the functions like this
doesn't happen that often in machine
learning thirteen and would really
happen often in these this kind of
functions where you don't have any bad
local minima where there are two local
minima they are both global and the
reason why this kind of functions is
easier is that normally a local search
algorithm converts to a local minimum
with a virtualization under additional
you know if you assume additionally that
every single point has a strictly decade
curvature so this is not exactly true
but approximate you so local minimum
should be easier to find and and this is
also not just a vacuous property you
know many objects functions in machine
learning has been shown to have this
property you know I don't expect you to
rate this list but you know my name is
the testicle machine learning questions
have shown to have this property right
so and that's that you know is kind of
the focus of this talk right so what how
do we decide whether function belongs to
a family and this time I'm going to you
know kind of so very some of the
existing techniques and also you know
talk about some of the new techniques we
are trying from random field and
geometry so I'm not going to talk about
anything about the first type but there
are some recent progress in simplified
settings like Morris and unburned myself
do we have some paper on understanding
over permutation
for some simple linear dynamical system
starting and there are other papers for
over commercialization for deepening
artworks and recently with Jason and Ron
go so we have some paper that designs
new operating functions for like deeper
new what one layer you know when a new
artworks or one hidden layer networks
that we are going to put an archive
recently so but this is not what I'm
going to talk about today and let me
also just to mention that optimization
is not only thing for machine learning
if you care about machine learning so we
also need care about generalization but
in this talk I'm not going to talk
anything about that all right so so
techniques for analyzing the
optimization landscape can we how can we
prove that all local minima are global
so I think there are probably two type
of techniques so most of the techniques
that we are using in in these papers
that have set it in one of the previous
slides is you know I described them as
expected
analytical uses of automatic automatic
conditions and these techniques are very
good for matrix factorization problems
so let me just start with a warm-up so
for eigenvector problems so let's say
suppose we want to compute the top
eigenvector and this is the best
function is what we use
so we maximize this to the quadratic
form and over you see this is the
standard formulation and the claim is
that this you know object functions has
no bad local minima o local minima is
actually the only local minima actually
the only two local minima are the global
minimum so they are just plus 1 minus 1
plus minus the topic in vector so this V
plus minus V 1 there is a signature here
so of course this is a local maximum on
the manifold so let me have a simple
proof for this proof sketch for this so
just to demonstrate what I mean by
explicit analytical use of the automatic
conditions so let's say px is the
projection to the tangent space of the
unit sphere and the gradient on the
manifold of the function f is the
projection time
times X and the Hessen you know is there
has this formula we can compute it using
the sub formula from manifold you know
differential geometry so it's pretty
simple so the automatic conditions
consist of two things right so the
gradient is 0 and the Hessian is less
than zero right so that's some necessary
conditions for X to be a local Maxima
although they are not sufficient so
let's see first of what we can have from
the gradient is 0 so the Queenie in zero
means that if you plug in X into this
and you know plug in px is equal to I
minus XS transpose and the real ranch we
get and times X is equal to the scalar X
transpose MX this is a scalar times X so
this means that X is an eigenvector so
all the stationary points or critical
points are eigenvectors and now let's
look at which a conductor here can be a
local maximum so now let's look at the
Hessian where it has a is less than zero
no because it's a less than zero in a
PhD sense then you've plug in any vector
it is still less than zero so we plug in
you know be one in the quadratic form
this is less than 0 and this will imply
X is equal to v1 and the reason is below
so let's say you X is equal to VK and VK
is the case top top eigenvector which is
not you know but it's not that top
eggman the case the case egg vector and
K is not equal to 1 and we can you know
with a little calculation you can
compute the correct form out of the
Hessian at V K over V 1 so this is
equals to basically the eigen value the
top eigen value minus the phase eigen
value and by definition this is larger
than zero so this picture says that at
the point VK the gradient is zero but
you can move in the direction we want to
get a second order improvement that's
why it's not a local maximum so this is
how we do the eigen vector problem and
actually similar techniques can be used
for analyzing a
bunch of problems that that relates to
matrix factorization so here that
extensions so for example we can do an
alternative formulation of top
eigenvector we minimize M minus ax s
transpose for be nam square and you know
the minimizer of this is the scaling of
the top eigenvector and we can also do
you know SVD pca with a little higher
around let's say M minus X bar transpose
from L Square where X Y X is top ax and
y are top matrix matrices so weak and
also to matrix impatient which is
essentially something like this so you
have n minus ax s transpose and you do a
hard dot product and two wise dot
product with kind of our mass matrix
which is like the observation matrix
Omega is a random sparse dr1 matrix and
you can also do matrix testing where you
have this you know matrix and you apply
a linear transformation and you get a
linear random linear projection and you
measure that wound or so and all of this
you know you know functions have been
shown to have the property that our
local optima our global of course under
you know certain statistical assumptions
for the bullets three and four case and
sometimes you know to deal with some
weird corner case you have to item your
organization terms to make the landscape
better to have this property right so
and the coop strategy as a kind of
indicated are most electives so you have
that the gradient is 0 implies some
statement about a you know before we
have the gradient of 0 it mean priced a
axes eigen vector and then you have the
heading is a positive sign that this
implies some other statement about you
know the point X and you can manage to
statement and you get X is a global
minimum and this is basically what I
mean by you know expected analytical use
of the the optimality optimality
conditions and and for this stuff matrix
factorization problems the next thing is
that these two matrices
you know this two statement a and B or
maybe it's not just a single statement
is a sequence of statements so all of
these statements are off
guided by the linear algebraic
structures of the problems because these
are all about linear algebra all can be
formulated as simple SDP so just so all
of this problem can be solved by
comebacks taxation the largest
eigenvalue it can be 4-minute as this
one variable SDP yes so I definitely
agree with that although I think that's
might be it might be a bit chicken and
got sugar than that because you know you
can solve the topic in vector problem by
SDP but if you look at the SDV solver
you need to compute the high priority on
separate proof of the uniqueness of the
local optimal that I don't I I I'm not
aware Emil I think there's certainly a
quite a deep connections between tutor
cop convex case but I'm just saying that
some you know I don't know of any no
expected connections the I - minimize a
with that yes this but I'm just saying
that's to solve that SDP also need to
see solve active active problems you
know what is unique I'm proving the
local maximum of this is you know non
unique there are two local max maximum I
don't think that follows nicely to
oxygen
I don't know you know I would love to
know it if if there exists such a you
know proof okay yeah but but never let
us you know I'm not saying that this
some this gives us as you knows I need
you know strictly you know powerful
algorithms but today are you know also
in any practice they are much faster and
but of course these can be solved by
STPs right so
[Music]
okay so talking about speaking about the
proof strategies and also this stuff
proof strategies of them are good for
those situations where we have some
rotational invariance some in the in the
problem which also probably related to
some of the STP stuffs so and for
example you know if look at it species
objective if you will have some notation
R and then you write rotate x and y you
get x times R and Y times R and you get
exactly the same equivalent you know
like a solutions in terms of the
function value right so and it seems
that in this type of techniques might be
a little limited especially because some
we need to kind of solve in some sense
this statement a is a way to kind of
solve you know the the first-order
critical point solution and the first
first other critical point optimality
conditions so so so basically you know
it seems that this table techniques is a
little bit restricted to the problems
with rotation inverse and we are looking
for whether there's any other techniques
for analyzing landscapes so that's what
I'm going to talk about in the next 20
minutes so the techniques that we are
trying to use is catalysed formula this
is a counting technique that tries to
count how many local minima of a
function of a function so so let me just
to define the problem that we are using
this cash transfer criteria is formula
on so problem definition for 10 set
accommodation is that we were given a
tensor T of the form that T is a sum of
1 tensor so this is a sum of AI to the
tensor power for each of these AIS is a
T dimensional vector so T is the D times
T times T times T dimensional our tensor
and we are given the entries of T and
our goal is to find the component AI so
of course we need to make some
assumptions on AI so that we can recover
of the areas let me specify that in a
moment so the feature of this problem is
that it is a little bit beyond linear
algebra so he only has some permutation
bars you can only permute our eyes
you can Prometheus in any way and you
get the same key but you can rotate them
to get the same key so so this is a lot
of balance the case cases do we know how
to solve a non-convex program program
that we are interesting is the following
we just maximize the injection norm of T
so basically we have a variable X even
when Matt maximized the inner product
between T and X with 10 to power 4 and
because T is of the structure so
actually this object functions can be
written as a sum of a I dot X to the
power 4 and we maximize it over you need
the unit sphere in particular if these
areas are random then for large range of
parameters and indeed no gradient
descent funds world areas empirically
when a is a random so you know
empirically we can only test it to you
know fall you know I think I tested for
dimension D or the cost island so we
believe that the right correct we hope
that this is true for N is less than D
Square t square by the program we cannot
test that star relate because if these
are thousand is in or thousand squared
and you know we don't have the
computational power to really test it
that's thoroughly so yeah I'm just
talking about the empirical factor yeah
so appropriately I don't know exactly
but I believe it could be d square I
don't know so and the question is can we
explain this back harking the landscape
let's keep our function f let me also
just mention that again this is a
problem that can be solved by some
different programming so certain cases
can be solved the import on with time so
there's a foobie algorithm and also we
have to bribe the sum of squares
algorithm for it and there are you know
speed-up of some squares algorithm for
you know some certain cases but here you
know if they are random but sparse do
those techniques work equally I think I
think for the sum of squares algorithm
that we did with some Jonathan stock
David I would guess there is a good hope
because the techniques there is pretty
generic and you only
you know step some inequalities fall you
know some inequalities by a sum of
squares proofs so I think there's a
reason which a good chance that is
Castillo work approach non convex
programming approach I don't know I
think it's there's a chance that it can
still work yeah yeah all right so yeah
so but the point here yes again the
point here is that we are trying to
understand uncle maximization so just to
give some intuition so the easy case is
the case when all of the AIS are
thoughtful and when they are orthogonal
actually we can you know without loss of
termina assume that each of a is is just
a based in the natural basis vector and
then the object function sees becomes
that you know each of a iti then this is
just the sum of the fourth you know the
fourth power of each of the chorus is
just the force norm to the power form
and constraint is that the two norm is
what so and the global Maxima is exactly
you know x equals to e i for i from 1 to
d and the value has of the function is 1
and and we can prove that a local minima
global and actually the proof is also
pretty straightforward it follows from
this kind of explicit analytical uses of
muriatic conditions so if x is a
stationary point you can you know write
down the no gradient and basically the
way do you think about it is that you
know if you the green is zero means that
you cannot move on a manifold to any
place so basically means that the the
unbidden gradient is our salt is a
parallel to x and if you solve that
equation you can get it x really have to
be of this kind of form right so all of
the entries can with each of the chorus
only takes three entries plus C minus C
and zero so and and then you look at all
of this possible critical points they
are kind of explanation above such
critical points and you look at and you
look computer heading for all of them
and you will see that only X is equal to
ie I can be a local maximum and all
others are not
setup was so so this is a kind of easy
case and the hard case is the over
complete case well early is larger than
D so the rank is a lot of a dimension
and we make assumptions the randomness
assumption just to make the problem
it'll be easier so we assume that each
of the AIS are random from random
Gaussian so we choose the covariance to
be well over d x and it is just to make
sure that AI is roughly unit norm so and
we have the same average function and we
know that the global Maxima are
approximately you know plus minus a1 up
to plus minus a n so and this can be
proof easily you know with a little
declaration using some kind of
Constitution or cardigan show that for
all X f of X is less than 1 plus minus 1
plus epsilon absolutely depends on the
you know the parameters like indeed and
and you can also show that for every I
also choose loss value around 1 and you
can also show that if the function value
is close to 1 then axis has to be close
to one of the trust - areas so this kind
of all of this can be done by you know
constitutional qualities and and we
don't care about we care about the local
maxima and this is what we can prove
it's not a completely result as you can
see so we can prove that X F X has
exactly two a local Optima to a local
maxima and they are roughly equals two
plasmas plus minus a 1 up to plus minus
a n in the super level set that contains
all of the X such that the function
value is larger than one point zero one
times the value of our random
initialization so by the pain the value
of our random Association basically is
expectation of effects you know by
taking expectation over the random
choice of X and this is actually equal
to 3n over d square and the our
parameter setting this is much less than
what so basically the kind of idea is
that you know we have you know the
landscape look like this this is a plot
for accurate three-dimensional case so
they are
all of this local maxima I was a 2 a 3
and minus a 1 minus a 2 minus a 3 and so
the largest values are 1 and the
expected value is 3 and over D Square
and what we can do is we can show that
you know in this rich region there is no
by local minima optimal local maximum
and but between here we don't really
know what happens and and let me just
mention that just mention that actually
it here there is um there are a lot of
points here like Oh actually the problem
measure in this region is close to 1 so
we cannot renomii tries to get into this
region although from another point of
view this region should be pretty easy
for optimization if you run the
experiment you know with a few number of
steps you get into this super level set
and actually we conjecture that with
constant ABAB steps you can get into
this super level set I don't know how to
prove it so this is what we can prove
and now let me talk about the techniques
so we're using this case red formula so
this case red former is general
techniques to count how many local
minima for data function has actually it
can be even more general than that as
you can see so the tailor setting is
that we have two random functions
actually as these are two random you
know field two random vector field so P
is a function from the dimension to D
dimension and Q is a function from D
dimension to K dimension and we have a
set B which is in K dimension and we
care about this integer random variable
this is this number n is equals to the
number of points such that px is equal
to 0 and Q X is in the set B
and we care about expectation of this
number of this random variable and here
is the formula so under certain
regulatory conditions the expectation of
n is equals to this you know this this
quality so it's integral over DX and the
the integrand is expectation of you know
a bunch of kinetics okay so and you know
the full proofs you know can be funny
idler and Taylor and there's a long
history of um of work on these type of
formulas so the intuition is that it's
kind of really just a switching of
expectation integral so the first thing
to prove this formula the first thing
you want to do is that you want to write
a nice integral so write an integral
over DX and you know this is basically
our indicator function in some sense but
it's a you know it's a proximate
indicator function and this determine of
gradient of P is can have the Jacobean
to to do the change of variable and you
know that doesn't really matter that
much so basically you write as integral
over X and then you take expectation for
an expectation and you change the order
of expectation and integral properly so
it's basically accounting technique in
some sense you can think of it as you
know for every point I want to count
what is the chance that this point is a
local minima and then I adopted the
chance but of course that's it kind of
the discrete way of thinking about it
okay so and you can see because this is
very general you can use this to count
how many local Maxima basically the only
thing we do is let's say say we have a
function f and we take P in a previous
slide to be the gradient path and Q in a
previous rise to be the Hessian of the
madness of the high C and then you take
B to build a set of positive some
definite matrices and then the number of
local Maxima is just equals to number of
points such that px is 0 which means the
grid in 0 and Q X is positive
semi-definite which means that the
original function
you know has a negative - and you just
plug in P and Q with these two choices
and you get this complex formula alright
so and you know and then you can extend
this to random functions on the manifold
which is the case that we care about
you only need to replace greeting and
greeting square the Hat by the green has
seen on the manifold and you can also
extend this to the setting where you
care about a super level site maybe I
should skip this slide because I have
limited time but it's kind of Chum
you know tribute the only thing you need
to do is indicator here to indicate that
super level set
but let's not care about this I guess I
have limited time but let me still do
the the simple case first purpose super
Co spin class model so this is by all
fingers oh and they want to care about
they want to count how many local minima
a different level set of this that this
random function has so this is a random
completely random polynomial so our case
is a structured random paloma this is a
completely random polynomial and for
this case actually some relatively
straightforward to use this formula
because you can compute the the
distribution of the gradient and it
turns out to be a Gaussian vector and
the distribution of the Hessian turns
out to be a Gaussian orthogonal in
sample matrix and you know this can be
verified easily maybe let me skip this
so basically the point here is that if
you look at this formula every quantity
in this formula has no intensity and if
you look at this formula it only depends
on the highest through the spectrum of
the hessian because you know care about
determinant of the hessian and all of
the you know quantities actually have
close form so the close for the
eigenvalue distribution of the hessian
has closed form because it's gioi matrix
and so is for everything else so
basically use this formula can get
expectation and the conclusion that they
have from this paper is that most of the
local minima have similar function
values
yeah so this is some yeah
this notation is a little yeah probably
not rigorous so so this is the density
of the gradient all right let me see
so this is a density of the green value
at zero so without the zero this is
density of liquid it and you evaluate X
zero because you care about when the
gradient is equal to zero that's why you
put zero here if you care about when the
grid is equals to you and then you put
you here all right
so okay let's go back to our trinomial
our polynomial is a sum of random linear
polynomial to the power 4 so and we can
complete a green hassle so if you do a
little bit change of variable you
different alpha I to be the inner part
of a + X + bi to be the projection for a
I to the tangent space then we can write
the green Hassen as follows so the
gradient is the sum of our I cube times
bi and the Heston has this formula so
the exact term you know former doesn't
really matter so enough I had Gaussian
distribution bi also has Gaussian
distribution and the good news is that
the dispersion of the gradient and the
Hasson don't really depend on X because
the whole system is the rotational
environment so we don't really care
about X so the integral over X is not
it's not a issue so but the bad news is
that the Hessian we don't have closed
form formula for the eigen value
distribution of the Hessian because the
Hessian looks like this so this is kind
of like a Wishart matrix but actually
there's a generalized Wishart matrix
with some waiting in front of each of
the term and the weight thing the weight
is also a square of the Gaussian and you
also have some you know random identity
just random scalar times and anything so
that's kind of the bad news and so
basically we don't know the exact I can
write a value distribution for the
Hessian and so the question is how do we
you know compute evaluates the
pasteurize formula
so so there are two ideas that I'm gonna
discuss in this talk
so the first idea is that how do we
change the evaluation problem to a
summation problem the cuss words found
will give you exact you know formula for
the exact expectation and but we don't
know how to compute that maybe we want
to know do some inner quality instead
equality so the the trick is that we
divide but the level set into two level
says when the first set is that the set
of s one that contains all of the points
with function value very close to what
so in some sense this is the site of our
points that are very close to a global
minimum and as to is the rest of them so
and of course the local maximum number
of local Maxima is as is equals to the
local Maxima in both of these two sets
and we use different techniques for
these two sets for the first aside where
this contains the set of points that
they are close to global Optima then we
use some other you know Alan Eriko
techniques that we kind of similar to
what we described in the first part of
the talk so this doesn't use tektites
wise formula and for this part we use
case res formula and we but we use as a
spent version of it we compute expected
number of local Maxima yes - and we
found that it's less than you know an
inverse exponential and that means a bit
high probability this number the number
of local Maxima has to is exactly zero
so this is how you avoid the issue you
know of evaluating of formula exactly so
you only need to help this type of
estimation in surfy exactly evaluation
right so so so basically only the Arbour
balance for the cash prize formula so
now how do we all have an upper bound so
recall that we still have the
determinant issue right so we had this
sum determine of the Hessian and for
most part of the paper we basically use
this simple a MGM inequality to bound
the determinant so we have the
determinant of a matrix and times the
indicator m is a PSD matrix
it's less than the average
of the eigenvalue to the power D right
basically this is just that this is the
product of eigenvalues and conditioning
on the the eigenvalues are posted and
it's a product of any things these
things and you bonded by the average of
them to the power D and this is
reasonable time when M has similar
eigenvalues which is kind of the case
for all of us because n with the random
matrix and of course we also need other
random matrix balance for cases when
this is not tight you know there are you
know multiple different sub cases that
we need to deal differently using
manometric theory so so basically so
basically i think let me just briefly
discuss you know before wrapping up let
me briefly discuss how why we can only
do it for the less super lame-o set but
not fall over our severe so as I said
the first difficulty is that when the
functional value FX is very cool where a
fact is very close to expect in 5x which
means that X is not in a level set then
the Hessian is a roughly our general
Fisher matrix with mean zero and the way
it has mean 0 this type of inner core is
not very tight at all because in most of
the cases this indicator itself as the
eigen values are not so you know are
equal anymore is sometimes difficult to
is that I think this is an even more
fundamental which is we here we have to
care about all them the inverse
exponential probability event so the
standard random matrix theory it doesn't
really suffice because you know
especially the time I mean the type of a
high probability event is not the only
thing we have to care about we also care
about those events with very high
probability this is because at the end
of take we have to take an integral over
all point X and that means that you
multiply the whole thing by you know
exponential so which means that the X
met exponential you know matters and
actually the base in exponential matters
all right so let me just use one minute
to discuss the open question so the open
question you know as a I you know
it basically is whether we can prove
that the project accreting assent from
random initialization converts to
approximately one of the AIS and so
again you know basically the missing
part is what happens in this region and
there are two possibilities one is that
they are exactly two and local minima
Optima on a exactly on the whole
universe appear if that's the case then
we can prove this algorithmic result and
but actually I don't strongly believe in
this because we need some heuristic okay
creation and try to count how many local
minima here and it turns out you know
our titration is not rigorous and that
the number we got is very close to 1 to
the power D like it's kind of like point
nine five to the power D so so you see
that it is some it's a little bit tricky
because if we did the calculation
wrongly or you know some of the
approximation is not quite correct
it might be larger than you know longer
than one so so that's why I'm I wouldn't
strongly believe in this but empirically
this conjecture is true
it sounds like - so another possibility
is that from running transition after of
worse type of project Aquino sent the
each fall into the super level set s so
it's possible that there are some local
by local optima here but you just never
hit it because you start with random
initialization and we do have a special
reason to conjecture that there is only
over steps there are only upstairs we
only need big avoid steps because if you
believe that at the first constant of
steps you can always make the same type
of progress as what you make in the
first step then you're you're going to
have this of course that's not a proof
but that's how we got number of what all
right so okay so just to wrap up so I've
discussed two type of techniques for
understand the landscape of the
optimization
functions so one is using explicit
analytical uses of ultimate optimality
conditions and the other is to use
Casarez formula and you read
theory and of course wealth the open
questions brother open question is
whether we can have more mathematical
techniques to analyze the know I think
the most most of the the reason is that
we don't know how to solve the GUI Danny
zero equation right so in the in the
region we use cash price basically we
want to kind of we don't know nothing
about that region right we don't know
where the critical points are we don't
know whether you know we don't have any
clue so so it's very hard to use any
analytical tools that's most of the
problem and the for the reason we Oh
actually I works in further for the
reason we don't use cash oh I don't
think it's constantly around the
expected value you know it it cannot be
right because you are looking at the
whole universe fear right so the
expected value for every point is always
the same because this is nutritionally
so if you look at the expectation of the
gradient with the back to the randomness
there is always a it's always the same
so but of course if you fix the random
you know lectures then you look at
agreement at the other points then they
cannot be the same so the Constitution
doesn't work yeah probably that's the
shortest answer
oh okay so the main theorem you passed
oh sorry I think I gave it earlier right
some number times the sentence oh so
okay so the easiest way is that you just
replace this big send this by 3 all over
D square that's what we prove yes
Stenberg yeah and actually the yes this
would be expected values of the random
excitation so sometimes if you
initialize it in some way so that you
get a little bit better than
randomization then then the rest of the
job is the version that I didn't talk
about is the version where you have a
super level set you need to count how
many local Maxima in a super level set
this is straightforward extension of the
of the usual formula you know you
actually don't have to be super level
set any pre described sets you can count
how many local minima
oh no comebacks Medeiros
this is oh yeah so one of the things you
thought could happen for your
confirmation photo is that there are
local Optima yeah is that is there any
problem we're rigorously won't improve
things like that no not at all so I
don't have I don't know of any good
techniques to really distinguish
randomization from arbitrary
interpretations so yeah that's a that's
a fascinating question you know I don't
know how to I don't have an idea for the
moment
any other questions
the the resection should be left outside
[Applause]